So this is how our history with shared counters
would work. We have the program counter. We take
some of the lower most bits, use that to
index into what we will call PHT or Pattern
History Table. This is a table that simply keeps
the history bits alone for that branch. So if
we have an 11-bit history, this table will have
11-bits per entry, so it doesn't have the 2-bit counters.
But we do need the 2-bit counter to eventually
tell us whether the branch is supposed to be taken
or not taken. So what we do is we
take this history from this table, combine it in some
way, usually using an XOR with a bits of
the PC. And use that to index into what we
still will call the Branch History Table. This Branch
History Table has entries. Each of these entries is just
a single 2-bit counter. So each entry's very small.
And that entry will tell us whether we should be
predicting taken or not taken. When the branch outcome
is known, we use the same history and PC combination
to index back into this 2-bit counter, increment or
decrement it, based on the current decision on a branch,
and then we shift in that pattern also into
the PHT entry, so that this history is ready for
the next prediction on this particular branch. So
the idea is that the program counter here tells
us which branch we're talking about. We hope that
the Pattern History Table has one history per branch
that we have. Different histories and different pieces
will result in different 2-bit counters being used, and
thus, the decisions will be made for kind of
like the combination of the history and the PC.
Note that it is possible for another PC to
map somewhere here, but that history, when XOR with that
PC gives us, maybe, the same 2-bit counter. So
it is possible to have some overlap here. But the
idea is that this way, for each PC, we
have a single history of all the possible histories that
is, that is two to the Nth of them. We
are really using only a very small number of counters
because very few histories are actually happening, and
that means that if you have a relatively large
array of 2-bit counters the possibility of conflict is
very low. But this allows us to have a
lot of bits of history. For example, if we take 11-bits of PC, and we index into
the PHT with them, we will need 2 to
the 11th histories times, let's say 11-bits of history.
We excerpt those 11-bits with these 11-bits. So we have 2 to
the 11th 2-bit counters. So the overall cost of this
predictor will be 2 to the 11th times 11 for the histories
plus 2 to the 11th times 2 for the counters, which ends
up costing us 26 kilobits. This is much less than what the
cost would be if we had an array of
2-bit counters for each possible history in each entry
over here. Pretty much, these 2 to the 11
times 2, will need to be in each entry here,
if we didn't do the XOR like this. Note
also that we don't have to have this numbers
here and here equal, we can, for example, take
something like 10-bits of the PC, to index into the
PHT, which gives us only 2 to the
10th histories and have a 16-bit history, so that
we can have 2 to the 16th entries here and so on. It still will keep the overall
cost in the, you know, tens of kilobits,
not megabits or gigabits that we would get if
we tried to put together long histories with dedicating
2-bit counters for each possible history in each entry.